les gars très cabaret internement
dénoncer les abus psychiatriques voilà
l'action qu'a mené samedi la commission
des citoyens pour les droits de l'homme
en manifestant devant plusieurs centre
hospitalier des yvelines dans le viseur
de l'association les mauvais traitements
infligés aux malades ou encore des
procédures d'internement à la demande
d'un tiers appliquées de manière abusive
vous avez plus de 85% des procédures qui
sont utilisés de cette façon donc pour
nous c'est inacceptable parce que ce
sont des milliers de personnes qui sont
hospitalisées dans le département des
yvelines avec beaucoup moins de garantie
pour le patient parce que vous n'avez
qu'un seul certificat médical qui est
nécessaire au lieu de deux et vous avez
l'accord de la famille qui n'est pas
obligatoire et même la famille peut être
en désaccord avec la procédure
d'hospitalisation sous contrainte et les
psychiatres aura le dernier mot que
procéder à l'internement la personne
l'association dénonce l'excès de pouvoir
des psychiatres mais aussi le manque de
contrôles de la part des autorités
depuis 2006 notamment à plaisir vous
avez aucune visite ni du préfet ni du
président du tribunal de grande instance
or ces autorités doivent visiter
l'hôpital au moins une fois par an pour
l'association les soins administrés aux
balades sont également considérée comme
inadaptée vous savez quand quelqu'un se
fait hospitalisé sous contrainte c'est
quand même sont des traitements très
lourds qui lui sont administrés avec des
effets secondaires dévastateurs avec une
dépendance très forte et vous avez aussi
des mauvais traitements vous avez aussi
les électrochocs un la sismothérapie v
une belle soeur qui vient d'être interné
en hôpital psychiatrique on la met sous
psychotropes elle est devenue un vrai
légumes alors que pour évidemment elle
avait des problèmes psychologiques c'est
un fait mais les médicaments qu'on lui
donne ne l'êtes pas bien au contraire
bien au contraire elle est encore plus
dépressifs qu'elle ne l'était avant des
appels à témoins ont été lancées avec
une distribution de tracts pour
recueillir des témoignages mais aussi
redonner de la valeur à la parole des
malades